ah oui c'est ça ça après 4 ans d'attente
et près d'un an de travail l'édition
2024 du Petit Futé Eveline va enfin voir
le jour dans cette nouvelle version
restaurant hôtel ou encore lieux
culturels autour de chez vous ont été
soigneusement sélectionnés c'est la
qualité de des produits la qualité
d'accueil la qualité aussi de de
géographique aussi on bout de personne
dans dans la qualité on peut avoir des
restaurants étoilés comme des petites
auberges avec une petite grand-mère qui
fait des plats justement de grand-mère
cette année l'auteur de cette édition
est marine Pasquet SAES pour cette
ivelinoise d'adoption l'écriture du
guide lui a permis de redécouvrir le
département il y a un travail de
recherche parce que le guide n'avait pas
été mis à jour depuis 2020 donc il
fallait ben vérifier au niveau des prix
des si les restaurants étaient toujours
ouverts les nouveautés qui se sont
ouverts entre-temps même moi qui habite
dans les ivelines ça me donne de bonnes
idées de balade depuis plus de 40 ans le
Petit Futé est un incontournable des
guides touristies faire partie de la
sélection du livre est une fierté pour
les établissements pour nous la fierté
c'est d'être sur la couverture c'est que
le domaine de Dierre se trouve à la sur
la couverture ça veut dire que ça y est
notre notre travail depuis 5 ans de mise
en place de la notoriété du domaine de
Dierre bien évidemment on devient un des
monuments emblématiques des ivelines on
espère que ça va faire venir du monde
qui vont venir nous voir sur ce beau
domaine où on a à la fois du patrimoine
des animaux de la nature et on
représente assez bien les evvelines pour
ça et des visiteurs dans les evvelines
il devrait y en avoir en 2024 avec les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques pour
répondre à la demande près de 15000
exemplaires seront en vente dès le 7
février thématique bien spécifique